jennifer lopez and ben affleck are in it
for the long haul
sosa's longtime friend and owner of
leopold's ice cream stratton leopold
i've known ben since 1999.
the former movie studio executive met
the couple in hollywood
when i did the second picture with ben
in vancouver we did paycheck up there it
wasn't meant to be
they were together then the first time
and she was there with us on on set
there and then of course together again
forever today he's most likely to see
benefir and savannah georgia 45 minutes
from ben's estate in the location of
their second wedding he's
loves ice cream he's a friend the whole
family aspect is really important to him
they were here they were in town the
other day when ben comes in our
customers are generally respected that's
savannah generally stratton's taken over
the family ice cream business and it's
become one of ben's go-to sweet treats
in the area
i balance the cur the showbiz career we
have a great team here i'm always on the
end of a phone so that's not a problem
it's our 103rd year it's amazing to be
here i grew up behind the same soda
fountain we're excited ben loves our
butter pecan actually president carter
loves our butter pecan too we keep him
supplied in butter kind so they're both
in good company
[Music]
you